fin de ce journal tout de suite
décryptage et analyse on va plus loin
[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec Patricia
lemonnière aujourd'hui à nos côtés
bonjour Patricia et Bruno daroula
rédaction de France 24 bonjour Bruno
bonjour Raphaël elle se savait attendu
au tournant listres saliva un discours
inégal en clôture du Congrès des
conservateurs au Royaume-Uni sont partis
plongés en pleine tourmande par les
baisses d'impôts massives mais surtout
non financé dévoilé par la nouvelle chef
du gouvernement britannique voilà des
jours depuis son annonce la livre s'est
effondré les investisseurs doutent de sa
propre compétence à gérer le pays elle
maintient le cap écouter
nous allons alléger le fardeau de nos
impôts cet été nous avons eu un débat
intense à ce sujet mais le Parti
conservateur restera toujours le parti
des impôts faibles
baissez les impôts et la bonne chose à
faire sur un plan moral et un plan
économique
moral parce que l'État ne dépense pas
son argent mais l'argent des citoyens
économique parce que si les gens
conservent une partie de leur argent ils
feront davantage avec
c'est ce qui génère de la croissance
économique
elle a déjà du renoncer à la mesure la
plus controversée de son projet listrus
là suppression de la plus haute tranche
d'impôt sur le revenu et elle n'a
d'autre choix que de tenir bon Patricia
si elle veut durer c'est une femme qui
est connue pour son dogmatisme libéral
tout d'abord donc elle n'a pas
l'intention de reculer en ce qui
concerne sa sa foi entre libéralisme dur
et déterminé et donc là la seule le seul
problème qu'elle a en fait aujourd'hui
c'est son parti parce que son parti
renacle sont partis regarde les sondages
c'est à 13 points de voyez d'avance
peut-être pour les travailleurs voire 30
pour certains donc et surtout certains
commencent à comploter dans son dos en
disant que ma foi il se rapproche du
comité des
1922 là celui qui peut finalement
qui s'en rapproche ils ont commencé à
dire que ça n'allait pas ils sont une
petite vingtaine d'autres se disent ma
foi on va pouvoir peut-être travailler
avec les travailler parce que ce n'est
pas possible si vous voulez ça sa
politique effectivement de d'économie
parce qu'il va bien falloir financer
toutes ces tous ces allègements en fait
en quelque sorte d'impôts trouver de
l'argent et donc elle veut son ministre
de l'échiquier enfin son ministre de
l'économie en quelque sorte pour nous et
bien veut couper apparemment dans les
budgets de l'école de la santé enfin
autant de choses qui fait crier les
travailleristes et qui inquiète les
Américains et le FMI
spectaculaire à écouter une journaliste
de Sky News elle s'appelle better Rigby
elle a acquis une certaine notoriété en
interviewant justement à l'occasion de
ce congrès listrus écoutez la résumé les
premiers jours de ce qui s'apparente
déjà à calvaire
madame la Première ministre vous êtes au
pouvoir depuis 28 jours mais 10 d'entre
eux ont été mis sur pause en 18 jours
donc vous avez annoncé 45 milliards de
livres de baisse d'impôts sans donner
des détails vous avez provoqué le rachat
en urgence par la Banque d'Angleterre de
65 milliards de livres en obligation
vous avez laissé les travailler
maintenant de 33 points dans les
sondages 1000 offre de prêt immobilier
ont été retirés du marché malgré les
prévisions de croissance des taux
d'intérêt et maintenant la dame qui ne
cède jamais pour reprendre vos mots
annonce un changement drastique de
politique n'est-ce pas très certainement
le pire départ dans l'histoire des
premiers ministres
à Margaret Thatcher dont elle se vantait
en 1980 ça a bien changé depuis pour
nous c'est ravageurs intègrequisitoire
ah oui c'est ravageur parce que c'est
résumé en quelques secondes et c'est
très bien résumé donc d'ailleurs on voit
en face listrots qui est bon qui
encaisse quoi quand même d'autant plus
que c'est vrai ça fait un mois qu'elle
est au pouvoir mais là-dessus il y a eu
effectivement les les 10 jours de
célébration de la mort de la reine donc
elle a pas pu vraiment
imprimée ça marque et quand elle l'a
fait ça a été un peu catastrophique un
livre sterling a chuté parce
qu'effectivement tous les gens se
demandaient comment financer ces
allègements d'impôts donc du coup la
dame qui ne sait jamais a dû céder un
peu ou au moins temporiser notamment sur
la tranche le plus élevée de l'impôt sur
le revenu à 45% dont elle voulait faire
profiter les plus riches là pour le
moment alors dans son discours devant le
Congrès du Parti conservateur à
Birmingham elle a pas dit qu'elle
renonçait elle a dit qu'elle continuait
à croire en la vertu parce
qu'effectivement c'est une libérale
assez dogmatique
continuait à croire en la vertu de ces
baisses d'impôts et vous l'avez entendu
parler des impôts quand même comme
quelque chose de non moral finalement ce
qui bon ce qui pose question quand même
quelque part nous sommes totalement
voilà
ça se questionne mais enfin elle elle
reste elle essaie lorsqu'elle essaie de
faire un birmingle c'est de redresser un
peu la barre de rester un peu droit dans
ses bottes et puis effectivement de
contenir l'agitation interne qui
commence déjà effectivement à gagner le
Parti conservateur les prochaines
élections sont censées se dérouler au
plus tard fin 2024 puisque Boris Johnson
avait obtenu une très large majorité fin
2019 le mandat dure 5 ans au Royaume-Uni
le mandat de député le parti
conservatoire peut-il attendre d'ici là
sans tenter finalement un nouveau coup
d'état vous l'évoquez à l'instant
Patricia lemonyme enfin ce serait quand
même le deuxième en l'espace à peine
trois ans c'est possible comme si
quelqu'un de nouveau Fiat chaque nouveau
Premier ministre a le droit d'être
finalement une d'avoir une fois un vote
des défiance en quelque sorte convoqué
par ce fameux comité d'autant qu'il y a
quelqu'un en embuscade il ne faut pas
l'oublier outre originelson qui doit
regarder ça d'une façon très
intéressante mais il y a l'ancien
ministre enfin le challenger monsieur
sunac qui lui s'est frotte les mains un
peu parce que lui avait dit dans sa
campagne
quand il cherchait tous les deux à
gagner le à devenir Premier ministre il
avait dit dans sa campagne attention les
mesures qu'elles qu'elle veut faire sur
un plan économique c'est la catastrophe
moi j'ai la solution pour la grande
boîte
donc on l'avait accusé mais là il se
frotte les mains il est donc en
embuscade mais si c'était finalement le
moment de vérité pour le Royaume-Uni
sorti de l'Union européenne Bruno on va
voir maintenant finalement le vrai coup
du brexit l'économie britannique
peut-elle faire sans l'Europe c'est
peut-être ça aussi la question que pose
listrus aujourd'hui oui enfin sauf que
listrus elle pense comme d'autres
conservateurs que le brexit était une
bonne chose alors l'opportunité elle
veut faire Singapour sur la Tamise
sur cette ligne mais enfin là aussi
opportunité politique elle a bien évolué
et donc maintenant elle défend un peu
comme Boris Johnson l'idée que avec ce
brexit la Grande Bretagne va redevenir
le Global Britten comme ils disent
presque un Royaume-Uni non mais surtout
global tourné vers tout le reste du
monde avec alors il devait y avoir un
accord commercial avec les États-Unis
qu'on ne voit toujours pas venir avec ce
qui faisait ce qui fait encore le
commonweve mais d'échanger
d'augmenter pardon les échanges
économiques avec ces pays sauf que pour
le moment quand même la situation
économique n'est pas brillante que
l'économie britannique reste quand même
fortement dépendante pour près de la
moitié de ces échanges avec le continent
européen sauf que maintenant avec le
brexit c'est devenu très compliqué parce
qu'il y a les taxes on prend du retard à
Douvres et à Calais il y a l'histoire du
protocole Nord irlandais qui n'est
toujours pas réglé je vous rappelle que
l'histoire quand elle était ministre des
Affaires étrangères avait dit que la
Grande-Bretagne devait décider
unilatéralement de revoir ce protocole
sans tenir compte de la ville l'Union
européenne ce qui avait provoqué des
commentaires très énervés de la part de
l'Union européenne donc là aussi pour le
moment elle temporise mais cette
histoire de protocole d'Irlande du Nord
il va revenir sur le devant de la scène
cet état à prévoir après qu'il a décrété
l'addiction de quatre régions d'Ukraine
dont celle de zaporigia Vladimir Poutine
s'attribue aussi désormais la centrale
du même nom la première d'Europe un
enjeu aussi bien économique en termes de
sûreté nucléaire Patricia alors en
termes de sûreté nucléaire il faut
aujourd'hui on peut temporiser un peu
parce que vous savez que la centrale
pratiquement elle est totalement à
l'arrêt la température à l'intérieur de
la centrale nous dit-on à beaucoup
baissé donc il suffit si vous voulez en
quelque sorte que elle soit qui est un
peu d'électricité qui maintiennent un
niveau de température correct donc sur
un plan nucléaire pur la menace est
moins forte qu'elle n'a été au moment où
il y avait au plus fort au plus fort de
la crise donc là en fait cette centrale
nucléaire représente comme un symbole du
pouvoir j'avais envie de dire qui
s'effrite de Vladimir Poutine mais c'est
une carte là qu'il joue encore en disant
ah oui non attendez je perds peut-être
sur le terrain mais ça ça c'est à moi et
là c'est pour moi et c'est pour donc il
met quelque chose dans son panier pour
demain encore et là on est pas sûr que
effectivement les Ukrainiens ne veulent
absolument pas m'entendre parler on a su
que très discrètement ils avaient tenté
à plusieurs reprises de passer de
l'autre côté de la rivière parce que
grosso modo il y a la rivière la
centrale et après les les positions
ukrainiennes ils essayent de ils ont
essayé à plusieurs reprises de tenter
des passages par la rivière de débarquer
en quelque sorte sur la centrale cette
carte n'est pas n'a pas été jouée à fond
et il la garde à mon avis une fois
qu'ils auront peut-être réglé l'histoire
du sud de ce qui se passe vers Carson
que peut-on faire la year son patron va
en urgence acquief Bruno il veut mettre
en place sa fameuse zone de protection
autour de la centrale oui alors
l'ailleurs reste sur sa position en même
temps elle est un peu coincée parce que
c'est une instance internationale donc
ça fait des semaines qui dit il faut
absolument une zone de protection autour
de cette centrale nucléaire qui était
donc à la fois encerclé par les soldats
russes il y avait des soldats russes
aussi à l'intérieur et le personnel ukra
qui continuait un peu sous la contrainte
à travailler pour fournir de
l'électricité faut rappeler donc c'est
la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'Europe qui fournissait jusqu'à 20%
d'électricité en électricité jusqu'à 20%
de la population ukrainienne donc le
patron de la UEA il reste sur sa
position il va Kiev mais franchement on
voit pas ce qu'il peut faire là à partir
du moment où Vladimir Poutine
effectivement sort cette carte et des
crêtes que puisque loblast de zaporigia
et désormais partie de la Russie et bien
la centrale nucléaire aussi doit faire
partie cela dit il a quand même éprouvé
le besoin de signer un décret spécifique
sur l'annexion de la centrale puisqu'on
sait très bien aussi que la fiction de
ces annexions fait que les frontières ne
sont pas encore totalement délimitées
tout simplement parce que les Russes ne
contrôlent pas la totalité de ces
territoires
au chef de la UEA qui se déplace et qui
doit aller après à Moscou c'est une
claque de lui dire vous venez mais
franchement
qu'il comptait se rendre à Kiev pour
relancer cette proposition effectivement
et ça intervient vous l'avez dit Brunoy
alors que la Russie elle-même ne
contrôle pas loin sans faux c'est
régions qu'elle prétend avoir un excès
Patricia même vers louhanskales c'est un
juste là entièrement occupé bien même là
les Russes reculent oui alors ils
essaient de résister un peu plus au sud
ils ont essayé de monter une
contre-offensive mais on voit bien
qu'ils sont en train de de une
déliquescence au sein au sein de l'armée
le tout c'est de savoir est-ce que c'est
vraiment un effraytement complet le
début d'un effritement de l'armée ou
est-ce que ils vont ils vont se
ressaisir pour l'instant ce qu'on le
voit il y a eu des images qui ont été
diffusées aujourd'hui de de soldats sur
un char avec un drapeau blanc et qui
sort du char et qui se rendent à des
soldats Ukrainiens moi j'ai trouvé cette
image très forte parce que elle va
d'abord circuler sur tous les VPN en
Russie et donc au moment où on appelle
l'armée russe à se mobiliser à faire une
grande victoire on voit ses soldats qui
qui se qui se rendent et donc est-ce que
cette image là préfigure une débandade
ou est-ce que c'est juste une parenthèse
dans un moment de la guerre je ne sais
trop tôt pour le dire il faut dire que
Vladimir Poutine lui-même comme a
reconnu un peu entre eux c'était
difficile parce qu'il a dit espérer que
ces territoires allaient être stabilisés
et aujourd'hui c'est quand même un signe
assez intéressant c'est le patron du
comité de la défense de la de défense de
la Douma qui annonçait militaire qui a
dit mais enfin ça va il l'a dit comme à
peu près comme ça texto il faut arrêter
de mentir aux Russes le peuple russe
n'est pas idiot il sait très bien que
notre armée est en train de vivre des
moments difficiles il faut le dire alors
façon de mettre en cause le ministère de
la Défense est-ce qu'il est télécommandé
par Vladimir Poutine qui comme ça
à désigner en cas de graves difficultés
le ministère de la défense et le
ministre de la défense comme fusibles on
ne sait jamais trop mais enfin c'est
quand même dans un système aussi
verrouillé que le système russe assez
étonnant qu'un personnage comme ça fasse
sa déclaration alors autre élément
édifiant à qui pourraient d'ailleurs à
crédité ce que dit Bruno d'une prochaine
réorganisation d'état-major Vladimir
Poutine dessert le grade de colonel
général de l'armée russe aux dirigeants
tchétchène Ramzan Kadirov pourtant très
critique ces derniers jours envers la
conduite de la guerre par les Russes que
cherche à signifier d'après vous par ce
geste Vladimir Poutine a-t-il perdu la
tête ou bien au contraire s'est-il
pertinemment que bien c'est une épine
peut-être dans le pied de ces généraux
cadirov c'est ramzakador c'est un fidèle
parmi les fidèles c'est un dur parmi les
dures semblait déjà dit puisqu'il est
propre il l'a dit ces derniers jours
de 14 ans et 16 ans il appelle à
l'utilisation de l'arme nucléaire
tactique pour l'instant on ne sait pas
bien c'est un dur parmi les durs alors
c'est très drôle parce que Moscou
vis-à-vis de cadirof joue un double jeu
quand kadirof a appelé à l'usage de
l'arme nucléaire immédiatement après le
porte-parole à Dieu il a dit ça sur le
coup de l'émotion et puis après
finalement Vladimir Poutine le nom
général est-ce que c'est pour le
finalement pour s'en servir comme carte
pour après l'utiliser si besoin si
démissionne certains ce que vous savez
le pouvoir russe en fait Vladimir
Poutine lui ce qu'il veut c'est qu'on
avoir des fusibles donc il a besoin de
fusible donc il a chez higou le ministre
de la défense mais kadirof pour être un
jour un fusible et pour en faire un vrai
fusible valable il faut lui donner une
importance donc ça c'est on peut dire
que même si Vladimir Poutine semble un
peu en mauvaise posture il garde quand
même le contrôle et donc ces nominations
moi je regarderai ça avec
circonscription
il garde le contrôle mais on a
l'impression que tout ce qui fait ces
derniers temps lui connaît bien sûr la
voilà la réalité sur le terrain et que
donc du coup politiquement à Moscou il
est sous pression notamment de tout le
camp ultra nationaliste donc fait partie
cadirov donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'il a
organisé cette grande cérémonie
proclamant l'annexion pour leur donner
un peu du grain à moudre peut-être sans
doute aussi qui nomme Kader of KIT
effectivement plus tard à en faire un
fusible donc il contrôle mais il doit
contrôler un peu sur son aile gauche si
j'ose dire et sur son aile droite et on
sait pas trop de quel côté la balance va
pencher c'est ça qui est un peu
inquiétant quand même est-ce que pour
maintenir son pouvoir à lui finalement
au Kremlin un moment il va se dire bah
tant pis même si à l'arme nucléaire
tactique je donne voilà j'utilise les
ultras nationalistes ça me permettra de
rester au pouvoir où est-ce qu'il va
réussir à maintenir un
équilibre précaire c'est quand même une
question assez importante pour les
semaines à venir on a bien vu le chef de
la CIA américaine qui dit un homme
acculé au mur est un homme dangereux
donc il y a pas il y a pas de doute que
Vladimir Poutine actuellement parce
qu'elle est vraiment lui qui est en
charge des affaires militaires il a
repris tout ça apparemment dit-on donc
c'est lui qui n'est jamais une bonne
idée parce que c'est lui qui doit
finalement rendre compte à tous ces
militaires qui met en prison qu'il
arrête qui déplace etc il devra
peut-être un jour l'autre le rendre
compte et il devrait aussi rendre compte
à tous ces oligares qu'il fait passer
par la fenêtre parce qu'il n'y fait
passer par la fenêtre certain il dérape
il tombe mais il y en a qui tombent pas
donc prends des risques il prend
considérer les risques et c'est pour ça
que le responsable américain de la CIA a
dit qu'il fallait quand même considérer
qu'il pouvait être dangereux
des armes tactiques évidemment
nucléaires et le problème c'est que la
alternative est pas forcément
évidente
merci beaucoup Patricia Lemonia Bruno
Daru c'était ton va plus loin restez
avec nous dans 3 minutes un nouveau
journal dans Paris direct
[Musique]